well I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another edition of old versus
new we all know about Hannibal Lecter in
his history movies great suck great
sucked but one film that gets overlooked
at times is actually Electra's very
first appearance this is the 1986
Michael Mann film man under it holy shit
that's not Hannibal Lecter I thought he
was a British guy with his hair slicked
back
not a British guy with his hair slicked
back okay there's some similarities but
that's just one of the many differences
between two films based on the Thomas
Harris novel Manhunter and red dragon
both are very different but both are
actually very good too
they have their own unique style their
own way of telling a story in their own
way of showing what their characters are
going through but as always which one
holds up the strong which one comes
together the best which one toughen the
nipples with delight well we're gonna
find out today this it's old versus new
Manhunter versus red dragon
you
the only thing better than a hero is an
antihero the person who constantly walks
the edge of good and evil and these are
two great nuts that sounded
in the role of will Graham we got
William Peterson and Manhunter and
Edward Norton in red dragon both know
how to keep your attention and how to up
the intensity
they both do great work but in terms of
who's better that's a tough argument
let's look at Norton Norton is a very
no-nonsense kind of cop he's
straightforward hard-working and doesn't
take any bullshit even from one of
cinema's most famous killers that may
keep them and I might consider it know
do you dream much well goodbye dr.
Lecter you haven't threatened to take
away my books yet he has a gift for
sensing what a sick mind is thinking
which he sees much more as a curse
rather than a blessing but we're in red
dragon he's a healthy guy with a dark
edge Peterson portrays and more as a
sick mind that just barely made it over
to the good side and even then it's
constantly tight-roping it he doesn't
seem like a well person and deep inside
he knows he could just as easily become
one of those psychos he's brought in now
don't get me wrong they addressed this
in red dragon - but Norton still seems
relatively in control there's never a
cent that he could just snap at any
second
take for example when he's trying to get
into the criminals mind with Norton it's
very much along the lines of having an
epiphany you took your gloves off you
touched her with your bare hand and then
you wiped her down but when the gloves
were off did you even arrive with
Peterson you get the feeling he's
literally diving into the killer's
psyche almost like he's sickly enjoying
it you took off your gloves to touch it
in Jen
didn't you you son-of-a-bitch you touch
it with your bare hands and then you put
your gloves back on but while your
gloves were off did you open all their
eyes so that they could see you yeah
what'd you have for breakfast wasn't an
Egg McMuffin there's an Egg McMuffin you
fuck yeah because of this Petersen comes
across as more tortured and therefore
more complex you could see him very
easily going off the deep end at any
moment
Norton seems to have one foot firmly in
the real world so when Lecter makes the
comparison that they're similar it sort
of sounds like your typical villain
speech don't you understand well you
caught me because we are very much alike
without our imaginations we'd be like
all those other poor dullards
in Manhunter he literally starts
freaking out just like an unstable mind
would so it makes more sense that
something like this would really get to
him
the Illinois who call me will goodbye
dr. Lecter you leave messages for me the
number you know how you call me the
reason you caught me will justify you on
the set
as much as I love Norton in this film
and he does give a solid performance
Peterson just had more of a sick twisted
mind that was more interesting to watch
Norton you're great the point goes to
Peterson you dirty little beast
now let's talk about our main villain
the tooth fairy
by when that have done a different film
Francis Dolarhyde aka a tooth fairy is
portrayed by ray Fiennes and Tom Newman
again this is a very hard choice as both
turned in very strong performances
Fiennes is certainly the more tragic
amplitude much more is given about his
backstory and you find yourself feeling
more and more sorry for him as you watch
you get the feeling that he doesn't want
to do this but it's abusive past mixed
with a sick mind creates a desperate
need to go through this bizarre
transformation I wish I could have
trusted you I wanted to trust you you
you felt so good you see more his
interaction with people how he works how
often he's in constant battle with
himself it's a great performance as well
as a great character Noonan's portrayal
is a bit different
the tragedy is there but it's more
hinted at he's left more in the shadow
which makes him come across as much more
creepy as well as more unpredictable you
are privy to a great becoming and you
recognize nothing you're an ant in the
afterbirth this your nature do it
incorrectly trimble most of his scenes
don't even have music it just lets the
suspense and mystery of his actions fill
the fear of the scenario so in this case
we once again have two totally different
interpretations and it all depends on
what you find stronger the killer you
have more compassion for or the killer
you're scared to death as much as I love
both of them I again had to go with
Manhunter because the less you know
about what's going on in his brain the
more unpredictable and therefore
frightening he is but he still has that
level of depth that is needed as well
and you do see the pain he's going
through it's just not explained through
words it's explained for visuals and
music and in the film that plays pretty
strong tough call but I have to say with
Manhunter again it's just another
example of less is more point goes to
the old don't you reckon
now let's get down to the one you all
want to talk about Lecter true he's not
the main villain in either movie and one
does have him much more than the other
but I still stand by the fact that these
are two very good performances and
deserve to be looked at
this is the best Lecter
now a lot of you might be thinking this
is a no-brainer
Hopkins turn this role into an icon and
whenever anybody even says the name
Lecter they immediately think of him so
obviously he should win but Brian Cox
actually has a very different and
surprisingly effective take on the role
as well he's a fast talker he's
obnoxious he's a jerk but he'll
Samantha's to get inside your head in a
matter of seconds but you might be
curious to see if you're smarter than
the person I'm looking then by
implication you think you're smarter
than me since you quote me I know that
I'm not smart then how did you catch me
you had disadvantages what disadvantages
you're insane
Hopkins are slower and more calculating
then by implication you think you're
smarter than I am since it was you who
caught me no I know I'm not smarter than
you then how did you catch me you had
disadvantages what disadvantages
you're insane but there's also something
even more frightening about a guy who
just has you paint the minute you walk
in and uses that almost immediately to
start manipulating you
you came here to look at me here they
all sent back again to Lear I want your
opinion I don't have one right now but
when you have one I'd like to hear it
when you get more flowers I'd like to
see them too you can call me when I have
to call my lawyer they bring me a
telephone would you like to leave me
your home phone number
Hopkins could be evil but you never
really got mad at this guy you just want
a smack in the face half the time but it
wasn't the act about you down was it
didn't you really feel so bad because
killing him felt so good and why
shouldn't it feel good what an asshole
in the book he's used about as much as
he is in Manhunter but I read dragon
they upped his role because of his
popularity we mustn't judge too harshly
we'll it was his first time have you
never felt a sudden rush of panic yeah
that's the fear we talked about on top
of that we've also had two other movies
to build out the creepiness so by the
time this one rolled around there was a
lot more build-up as to what to be
afraid we also see how he was captured
in red dragon which is interesting but
I'd be lying if I said I sort of didn't
want to see that like it's better left
to the imagination and come on how did
he survive that next time drop a safe on
them to be sure it's true this age can
be a little distracting in the movie but
I'm not gonna lie
the character does seem stronger when
Hopkins is doing it no I'm sure a lot of
that has to deal with the fact that
there's more time and two other movies
to develop him and on top of ads and
oscar-winning performance but still I
think it's worth noting Cox's
performance as well yeah it's different
and there's not as much of him but just
like Michael Mann do with the other
killer there's little music little
shadow the creepiness just comes from
the performance and the blunt harsh
reality of the situation with that said
though it's pretty hard not to love a
guy who can find the real meat of a role
play goes to the knee
so
now the Saracens blokes are always
filled with colorful characters and
these characters are just as colorful
dürer besa printing gas
again a lot of good performances and
actors to choose from let's start with
Graham's family in Manhunter the wife is
played by Kim dressed and the son is
played by David Seaman in red dragon
it's mary-louise Parker entirely Patrick
Jones while there is a connection in red
dragon with them Manhunter devotes
entire scenes to how this is all
affecting their lives even the scene
where he confesses to his son the
hardships of a sick mind and what it
means to live with it this is a very
strong moment there is much it said
you're in a special hospital and I was
transferred into the psychiatric wing I
bother she doesn't I don't know though
and I be only one distracted by just
wanting to see the old labels for things
oh my god has life and grape-nuts
ever changed their logo the nosy
reporter is also a lot of fun played by
a jackass Stephen Lang and a pump it's
Philip Seymour Hoffman both are great
but I think I prefer the snobby Hoffman
a little bit more that's just my
personal preference though Jack Crawford
has played well in both versions as are
the other investigators wait a minute is
that Barney in both of these movies holy
shit it is it's like he's in two
different dimensions but for me the
tipping point has to be with the blind
woman dating the killer played by Joan
Allen and Emily Watson and as cool as
Joan Allen is it's Watson who is far
more memorable much more time is given
to the romance between these two and it
shows in more detail how their
relationship grows which makes it all
the more tragic when you see where it
all ends up in the original it's a
little rushed the idea is that he
finally falls in love with a woman and
his psychotic killer mind doesn't know
how to handle it
but the attempt to kill her comes in man
hunter it's just sort of like another
kill
but in red dragon it's a real hard
choice and we know why we've seen them
grow close together the relationship
with the family is important in
Manhunter but I think the relationship
with her is more important in red dragon
it gives the character more of a purpose
as well as a weight factoring all that
in it seems like red dragon truly does
have the better
supporting cast the only by a little
point goes to the nude you know if you
don't want to talk that's okay once
again it's all tied up and it comes to
the most important element the store
those who read the book know that red
dragon followed it a little closer but
as we all know that doesn't always mean
it's gonna make for a better movie you
could make the argument that the ending
and Manhunter no different did at least
keep the story in mostly a three-act
structure
red dragon actually has two endings a
fake-out and then the real climax elem
it I'm not usually a fan of these fake
outz but at the same time it did allowed
Noren a psychological confrontation with
the killer as well as a physical one in
the original he just sort of fights him
off and that's it the rest of the two
stories actually follow pretty similar
the main differences or how much you see
of the family the girlfriend and Lecter
you see more of Lecter and the
girlfriend and red dragon but you see
more of the family interaction and
Manhunter for me personally I prefer a
more like Turan the girlfriend also the
story is a little bit more spelled out
in red dragon you can follow Manhunter
okay but a lot of stuff flies by pretty
quick for example there's just a line of
Manhunter when they say they search
elect her cell and didn't want him to
know in red dragon they actually show
what they had to go through to fool it
and whether or not it works in fact a
lot of red dragon is more visual I
remember much more of the creepy sets
the bizarre imagery and the dark shadows
now don't get me wrong
Manhunter look good too but when I think
of it visually I think more large
beaches and a lot of blank walls come on
guys can't you hang a picture in there I
guess there was that weird backdrop in
The Killers house but honestly I don't
get it I don't get it I don't like that
kitchen all of this contributes to tell
the story more fluently and providing a
more natural narrative and in terms of
all that red dragon does move smooth
again with the exception of maybe the
ending every scene seemed to fall nicely
into the next and the characters that
needed to be focused on were constantly
focused on even the ending isn't
horrible it just sort of seems a touch
unneeded like they could have had the
same psychological climax at the
killer's house without the family yeah I
know similar to what they did a
Manhunter but maybe with a little bit
more dialogue so just to emphasize I
truly do enjoy both of these films
they're both great movies but if I had
to choose which one I like better and I
do it would have to be red dragon the
only by a tiny bit point goes to red
dragon in my opinion the superior film
oh what a cunning boy you are
I'm the Nostalgia Critic and if you'll
excuse me I'm going to eat some liver
with some fava beans and a nice Chianti
hello takeout yes I would like to order
your finest duck deliver please oh yes
yes besides yes I would like a young
side of fava beans that would be lovely
yes something to drink what's still
Chianti that'd be wonderful what kind a
nice one Betty
seems to be wrong with this
would you like to leave me your home
phone number